hello everyone and welcome to another
very nice game from round nine of the
Croatian Grantchester being played in
Zagreb I know you were probably
expecting a game from round 10 but there
is a good reason I decided to skip it
and to show you another game from round
9 how do we have been requesting it and
it really is an interesting game how
about before we check it out we do have
a nice photo from this game so let's
check that out
here it is there you have it Magnus
enjoying his crystal clear water and 11
deep in thought there also you can see
that Magnus spent really really matches
Levin's shirt we don't have a clear view
of 11 spent but it would be really cool
if it matched Carlson's shirt so let's
just enjoy that and I did visit the
grand Chester once again today I tried
to collect the two signatures I was
missing Levinson the Wesley's I did I
wasn't able to collect West's but I did
get one from LaVon again he was running
he was again very late for the game but
he this time he decided to to do it as
he will probably be late every game
every day it's hard to say and also here
are some nice photos of me actually
collecting the signature so you know
that they are legit here's a photo of
Annan giving me his signature on the
board there you have it also here's a
nice photo of Magnus giving me the
signature let's just enjoy that for a
second and also here is one of his car
oh they have it he is just finished
giving his signature and well as I've
uploaded all the other photos to Mater
social media I will put a link to the
Twitter and Instagram pages so you can
check out the other photos if you're
interested in that as well
and also I've met a lot of you today so
thank you for that thank you for
introducing yourselves thank you for
asking me to take a photo with you even
I even received this very nice t-shirt
as you can see well you can't really see
it here from - very creative subscribers
but I do have a photo photo of it here
so this is well basically what's on the
t-shirt so you can see the michael towel
in the background that's me holding a
some sort of a flaming King there's some
chess ABS action going on over there
the gentleman is asking whether he
should pause the video or enjoy the show
it's a sort of a Prometheus theme going
on I
very creative and you know thank you
thank you very much for the t-shirt and
I did promise I would make a video in it
so here it is Vivek making the video in
it that being said let's enjoy the game
Magnus vs our onion it's around 9 and
let's enjoy it with d4 by Magnus Knight
to f6 c4 e6 and of course we all know
what's coming night of three d5 we have
the Queens gambit declined Knight the c3
and Bishop to b4 now I will Bishop to g5
by Magnus D chapters and c4 e for now by
Magnus and now c5 and Magnus already had
this position quite a few times
well specifically against Anand he had
hidden all T books Norway Championship
where he continued Bishop captures in c4
but he also had it against Ireland in
the Christian Grantchester a few rounds
ago we've covered that game was a really
insane fighting draw he also continued
Bishop captures and c4 but here he goes
for a really a well crazy line he 5 it's
a very rare line not a lot of people
play it but it is playable as Carlsen
place it yeah which you will see so it
seems like 11 blundered a night here but
of course it's not the case it's a
well-known line see capture son d4 now
11 threatening to capture the c3 Knight
as well with Knight captures on d4 and
now Bishop captures and c3b captures in
c3 and now Queen to a5 with the idea
that if Magnus captures on f6 then 11
can capture on g5 so Magnus does this
with it captures on f6 and now you don't
gain anything by capturing on c3 it does
seem nice well you cannot block with the
bishop because you lose the night here
but you can just like King e2 and black
doesn't really have compensation for the
piece there's no good way to continue
the attack so after it captures on f6 11
captures and g5 with Queen captures and
g5f captures on g7 Queen captures and
now Queen to d2 by Magnus now the knight
can move so the Queen will not be
pressuring the c3 pawn next move across
the wall and probably capture on c4 and
then decide whether to castle
immediately or or maybe play something
else with castles by 11 and now Bishop
captures in c4 with rook to d8 hmm now
preventing Magnus from
as long as if I would win the night here
so Quinta III you have to move the Queen
first and now Bishop to d7 Knight to c6
it's coming of course black is hoping to
get the bishop over here to this very
nice diagonal and here there is one game
where h4 was played and a lot of our
games was over 30 there are with King
side castle but here Magnus goes for
queenside castle and basically he boldly
goes where no man has gone before or
woman and it is as of this move that we
have a completely new game so Levin has
to decide what to do here now we have
it's a completely different character of
the position we have castles on opposite
sides of the board so it should get very
sharp so xi continues knight to c6 he
develops the knight prepares to bring
the the other rook into the game with
the shove the b3 by magnus preparing
bishop to see tutors well get the bishop
to a much more useful diagonal here
Bishop - eh opening up the rook and now
Knight captures in c6 with captures on
c6 now the bishop assumes this very nice
diagonal although there's never really
any danger of capturing it I mean you
don't really want an open G file here
for your rook
so Magnus goes h4 if you can have the
open G file you can have the semi open G
file so the idea is of course the rook
h3 followed by roped g3 a very nice rock
lift and you've won the game that's the
idea but of course xi has a say in first
Queen to f6 you get the Queen away from
the G file and now comes Luke 2 H 3 and
now b5 you want to start pushing your
pawns on the Queen side B for a4 and
start an attack against the white king
as well
rook the g3 check and now kink the h8 if
you go King to f8 you lose the game just
Queen c5 check and it's a game over you
cannot go to the G file if you go here
then well you just get roof 2g mate and
if you block with the Queen then it's
just captures captures and of course the
only well the only thing protecting the
Queen is the King's to just Ruby g8 a
nice deflecting move King captures and
you eliminate the Queen and this game
over
so after Luke G 3 we have King to h8 by
11 and now comes Luke to G for Magnus
prepares the rook to f4 to try and
create more pressure on the Kings side
with a five by 11 and now looked at f4
wouldn't an attack on the Queen Queen to
g7 still keeping an eye on this pawn
here a b4 is the idea so if you ever
captured an Queen to a one could be it
could be kind of an opening so magnet
sights the trade of pearl rooks rook
captures and e8 with rook after sandy
eight and now just g4 and it's really
weird how no one in this position ever
thought about castling queenside like
Magnus did here but it seems like his
King is fairly safe you know he is
somehow makes it work with B 411 also
continues the attack on the Queen side
and now g5 by Magnus of course you don't
want to capture on before we already
mentioned that it would be quite
problematic for example a4 and now if
you move the bishop you don't really
have a good Square to move its to if you
go to go shop c2 then just Queen e1
check there should be one and now there
should be five and it's just the roof to
see it is coming and it's all over
so not something you want to do but of
course who would actually capture here I
mean I don't even know why I mentioned
it g5 by Magnus and now training Queen's
here not all that great because after
captures captures and captures white and
capture on f7 and yes the material on
the board is equal for the moment but
Magnus has to Paulo porn islands 11 has
four point Islands and if anyone can
make it work it's it's well Magnus
Bishop of the c2 if comes then there
will be a lot of pressure against the h7
point could be very dangerous so here
after g5 will be capped resin c3 by 11
and now Bishop to c2 s plan just getting
the bishop to a more useful diagonal
with Bishop to b5 now attacking the
eighty pawn and now just look to s6 here
Magnus says okay you capture an A - I'm
gonna capture on c3 there's now the
Queen no longer guards the c3 pawn so
first Queen to f8 by 11 now comes Queen
captures in c3 and now what's the plan
here why did 11 allow this he played
Queen to f8 and he allowed this
beautiful diagonal to belong to
Carlson's queen and now you have so many
nasty discoveries being threatened for
example if you play something silly like
Bishop captures an a2 rook captures an
f7 check wins the game you either win
the Queen or you you block and then of
course it's checkmate so not something
you want to do so what do you do here
how do you defend this position with
what with black I'll give you a couple
of seconds Magnus is attacked and you
try and defend this position while I
give you a couple of seconds for those
of you who were able to do it
congratulations you have just repelled
an attack by world champion Magnus
Carlsen and for those of you who just
want to enjoy the show rook the c8 is
the strongest idea just attack White's
Queen if you try the Queen before it's
also possible but not all that great
white will just trade here captures
eight characters and rook captures on f7
and you don't get the capture on a2
because your h7 point is hanging and you
don't really have a good way to defend
it you have to play something like h5
alright then comes G characters and h6
on Poisson and after Bishop captures
here you will get rook to b7 going after
this pawn and it will be well just just
a much better position for white if not
winning probably winning but you know
you still have to work for it
so after Queen captures on c3 we have
looked to see a the strongest move by 11
and now how do you how do you play this
if you trade everything here now it's a
bit different for example rook captures
an f7 with check you get rook captures
and c3 yes you get this with check but
now King to g7 you are not not capturing
anymore pawns and now well it's actually
black who has a threat rook Bishop to b4
would you just attack the pinned piece
and you would win material here so you
have to prevent it
rook to f4 and now you get T 5 you try
and kick away the white rook somewhere
away from the fourth rank rook to a for
defending the a2 opponent here black
would be fine
the black the white rook is very passive
here and well even though white a white
is slightly better but not nothing to be
worried about here cross and decides
against that he goes
Queen to b3 and gets the Queen out of
the way and also threatens checkmate now
so 11 defense Queen to g7 and now we
have f4 you can go something like h5 h6
the g5 pawn will be hanging so here F
for we have King to g8 by 11 and now
again what do you play here well if you
try something like h5 which seems nice
then you get h6 and you don't really
have a good way of responding to this
you cannot capture as the route would be
hanging and black really wants to
eliminate some points here so Magnus
goes King to d2 now the bishop can
freely move but h6 nonetheless a really
beautiful move by xi as of course you
cannot capture so what can you do here
the problem is if rook captures which
seems to be nice then you get f5 and
again is the same idea
you cannot capture on poisson because
the rook would be hanging and now bush
of the e4 is a terrible threat black
would be much better here as you know
you would you would get crushed here
so after h6 Magnus continues with a 3 he
doesn't want to the pollinator to remain
a target with H captures on g5 f cat
person g5 and now rook the c4 just more
activity to the rook a threatening to
capture on h4 and now Magnus has to
decide how to go about this he decides
to defend his age for pawn but now he
gives away the e4 square to Black's
Bishop so Bishop to e4 11 not wants to
trade more pieces Magnus the client with
Bishop to b3 attacking the rook and not
rook the d4 check you cannot attack both
rook and Bishop because well rogue d3
just wins the Queen so we have kinky one
and now Bishop back to f5 and now this
rook is pretty much stuck there it will
be very hard to get it away from there
so across and continues to push with h5
rook to d3
attacking the Queen and now you have to
save the bishop as both the Queen and
the bishop are under attack wing to b8
check with Queen to f8 blocking you if
you go here with the kingdom
rook h6 just wins you have to give up
the Queen here so quinta f8 Magnus
straights Queen captures rook King
captures and now Bishop the c2
forcing the roof to move and preparing
to capture an f5 we have not real
captures in a three-level once the the
deep past H pawn with Bishop captures an
f5 e captures an f5 and now h6
creating well not creating it already
was a bad pun but now it's a protected
passport so what do you do here if you
capture on a3 would be a terrible
mistake to do because it would lose you
the game just h7 and now you don't have
a way of stopping the point if rook h3
just rook h6 and now after you capture
the two points create a wall here
against the black king you cannot
approach the pawns and next move a h8
will just win the game
so after h6 we have King to g8 by 11 now
comes a for not allowing it to remain a
target here and now rook to h4 here 11
again goes for the a4 pawn and you don't
really have a good way of defending it
well no way at all so Magnus just trades
rook captures an f5 we have rook
captures on a4 and our King to F to
Magnus starts bringing the King into the
game with rook the g4 now comes King to
f3 and now rook to g1 and here we have a
sort of a repetition King to F 2 root 2
G 1453 rook to g1 and after a Magnus
plate King to f2 it was in this position
that they agreed to a draw as well it
basically will be a threefold repetition
they agreed to a draw because even
though Magnus can win the a5 pawn it
doesn't mean much for example Ruby for
King f3 and now let's have to review one
you can capture an a5 but it doesn't
matter here black can just push f6 and
well you messed up White's pawn
structure and you will you will easily
draw this G characters on f6 rook f1
check King g4 you will capture here and
there's no way to push this for a win
King g5 you can just go rugby 6 you will
not allow the White King to approach and
the next you can just go king here
capture the pawn or if white prevents
you then
for example if he doesn't allow you to
reach the pawn well then the White King
cannot enter the position and you will
never Queen this pawn so that's
basically it of course both of them know
this and after King to have to they've
agreed to a draw so that's the
game I do hope you sorry about that I do
hope you enjoyed that as you a lot of
you have requested that I really really
do hope it was a nice game and like I
said I didn't show any games from round
10 even though it was supposed to be a
really intense line and there's a lot
going on here we already showed the
standings we said that it's basically a
raised between Carson and Wesley so six
and a half points the six but well
spoiler alert for those who don't want
to know the results from round 10 I will
not mention them
well Carson and Wesley drew their game
from round then but it was a I really
didn't like the game I really didn't
feel like Wesley tried to create any
chances with the white pieces he
basically just forced a draw and he's
probably hoping for for Magnus to
blunder in the last round and then he
can overtake him against someone else he
didn't really try to to make his case
against the leader of the tournament so
I decided it will it will not be a game
I should make a video about as it really
wasn't interesting at least to me and
usually I don't show the games I don't
find interesting myself and as all the
other games from Renton were also drawn
not not really a lot going on in many of
them I decided at least for the moment
not to show them and I do have a special
video planned for tomorrow for tomorrow
morning before the final round of the
creation grid and Chester my nephew
faced garry kasparov a few days ago in a
simultaneous exhibition it was a really
exciting game and I will be very happy
to show it to you but you will have to
wait for that tomorrow so that's the
game I do hope you enjoyed it I would
like to thank Valentin because the Congo
for a contribution to my channel thank
you a lot - really appreciate it
as usual you can check - on my previous
video Sarah think all for watching and I
will see you soon continuing the
coverage of this very nice event
checking up on your suggestions and
whatever we do here the usual thank
y'all I will see you soon and have an
excellent rest of your day